vamos a practicar la estimación de
multiplicaciones con decimales
aquí tenemos 7.8 por 307 esto a que será
igual aproximadamente este signo de
igual medio ondulado significa
aproximadamente igual pausa en el vídeo
y traten de encontrar el resultado por
su cuenta esta no es una multiplicación
que se pueda calcular mentalmente sin la
ayuda de un papel donde escribir pero
para darme una idea del resultado tengo
que darme cuenta de que esté 7.8 es muy
cercano a 8 y el 307 es muy cercano a
300 así que puedo estimar esto
multiplicando 8 por 300 con esto no voy
a saber la respuesta exacta es sólo una
estimación que me ayuda a saber el
resultado aproximado de esta
multiplicación nos dará una idea de cuál
es el valor aproximado de 7.8 por 307
cuánto es 8 por 300 bueno 8 por 3 es
igual a 24 por lo que 8 por 300 nos dará
2400 solamente le agregamos
20 si vemos las opciones nos damos
cuenta de que quienes hicieron esta
pregunta hicieron también una
aproximación muy parecida pues la opción
b coincide con lo que calculamos quizá a
otras personas cuando tratan de estimar
esto no lleguen a esta respuesta pero si
coincide con lo que calculamos nosotros
veamos otro ejemplo aquí nos piden
estimar el resultado de 99.87 por 19
pausa en el vídeo y traten de encontrar
un estimado de nuevo esta multiplicación
no es sencilla de hacer mentalmente pero
99.87 es muy cercano a 100 y podría
multiplicar el 100 por el 19 lo que nos
daría 1900 pero al ver las opciones
ninguna tiene esta cantidad sin embargo
1900 es más cercano a 2000 que a las
demás opciones así que esta es la
respuesta correcta como obtenemos los
2000 pues al redondear ambos números
99.87 lo redondeamos a 100 y el 19 lo
redondeamos a 20
por 20 nos da 2000 no es obligatorio
aproximar ambas cantidades el
multiplicar 100 por 19 nos da un número
más cercano al número real comparado con
multiplicar 100 por 20 pero multiplicar
100 por 20 es mucho más sencillo de
multiplicar mentalmente de cualquier
manera la opción correcta es la
resolvamos otro ejercicio aquí nos piden
encontrar un aproximado de la
multiplicación de 2.21 por 5.1 de nuevo
los invito a que pausa en el vídeo y
traten de encontrar una estimación de
esta multiplicación esta multiplicación
no es fácil de resolver mentalmente así
que vamos a redondear estas cantidades
para que sea más fácil multiplicar las
si redondeo esto a la unidad más cercana
esto será igual a 2 y si redondeo esto
también a la unidad más cercana será 5
esto es aproximadamente igual a 10 y la
opción que le corresponde es la opción b
quizá algunos de ustedes piensen que
pueden hacer estimaciones y cálculos
mentales mejores que él
hicimos aquí por ejemplo esto puede
aproximarse a 2 por 5.1 y es algo fácil
de calcular mentalmente esto es igual a
10.2 de cualquier manera esta opción es
la más cercana a este resultado por lo
que sigue siendo la opción correcta o
también pueden decir que esto es
aproximadamente igual a 2.2 por 55 por
12 10 y 2 décimas por 5 nos da una
unidad por lo que esto es igual a 11
todas estas son estimaciones que pueden
calcular mentalmente pero lo importante
es que no importa cómo lo hagan 10 es la
opción más cercana a todas estas
cantidades y 10 es una aproximación muy
natural al simplificar estos números con
esto terminamos